okay plant friends we are training
plants to climb our walls
on
blue mangrove youtube show
so plant friends this wall is my pride
and joy
of my apartment it is the green wall
that i installed with wally grove
planters
but as the wall has grown or as the
plants have grown on the wall
i have started to train the plants to
climb the wall or to at least look like
it is kind of cascading and growing
and climbing all over our white space
and
i can't believe it but the plants have
actually started to
attach to the wall this as
i jump on my um couch this
particular vine of this um jade pothos
has now attached to the wall with its
aerial roots
so if i can do it you can do it and this
is stupidly easy to do
so this is my masterpiece my larger
scale
um green wall installation i'm actually
going to show you a different plant that
has gotten some really beautiful
long hair that you're about to see and
i'm going to train that hair to grow
on another wall and i'm going to teach
you how to do it alongside me
okay this is like kind of an awkward
position but this is the corner that my
best gal
is in number one i've got a lot going on
here if you can see i have my entire air
plant collection
just wanted to give a shout out to
bulbasaur is that focused how freaking
cute is that
anyway um so my best girl
is here how fierce is she
love her i got her in mexico we were on
our vacation where we got engaged
and um these were all over the resort
and they weren't for sale but i just
like
harassed the manager of the resort to
ask if i could buy one
and they let me buy one and now i have a
beautiful memento when we got engaged
so anyway her hair has gotten really
long since i've repotted her
so i was thinking it would be fun to
have her start training up
uh trailing up the wall and maybe
climbing around our tv eventually
so i am going to show you how to do that
okay so training plans to climb a wall
is as simple as
this amazing product under 10 american
dollars
command hooks this is seriously how
simple this is and you can see i've like
broken into this i use them all the time
so these command you buy a package of
command hooks i
can't believe they're more than i think
seven dollars at your hardware store
maybe less i live in new york city so
everything is expensive
you attach the sticky that comes with
them and then you attach it to your wall
and they come off really simply
i don't believe that the roots also once
they do fix it fix onto your wall i
don't think the roots will affect like
your drywall or your paint or anything
but that's it so all i'm going to do is
i'm going to
fasten um i'm going to stick this on the
command strip
i'm going to stick it on my wall and i
think i'm going to train
her hair to go in two different
[Music]
directions
then
[Music]
hi friends how cute does she look who
wore it better
i don't know i think she might be a
winner
um it's really that simple so don't
think that the aerial roots are going to
start attaching to the wall
any time soon my green wall that i
showed you earlier in this visit
those roots have only started attaching
to the wall i think maybe in the last
couple of months
and i've had that green wall up for
almost two years but
who cares if the roots attach to the
wall or not you can just make it look
so cool and so fun so it's really that
simple you can
um check the command hooks that i use in
the show notes below
and i hope that you might want to get a
little green trellis going in your walls
and your urban jungles in your
apartments because
i have to say it gives the most amazing
jungle vibe and it is my favorite part
of
my home and now i've got two favorite
parts because
i think she is gonna grow some really
wild hair and i can't wait to see it how
it looks
so until next time my sweet plant
friends keep blooming
radio